Der SCP-Paderborn schickt sich an, das Aufstiegsrennen in der 2. Liga mächtig aufzuwirbeln. Der SSV Ulm hingegen will nach 2 Aufstiegen in Folge erstmal einfach nur die Klasse halten. Darüber spreche ich im Rasenfunk in der Liga Tour mit SCP-Fan Ramona Kleibaumhüter und Sportjournalistin Nadine Voigt von der Südwestpresse.
Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Russis zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bewühm.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Und nicht nur irgendeine Liga, sondern die 2. Bundesliga der Männer, die bekanntermaßen spannendste Liga der Welt, engste Liga der Welt, die beste 2. Liga der Welt. Ich bin der beste Host der Welt, nein nicht ganz, aber ich bin Marc Schwitzky, ich bin der Host für diese Sendung. Ich übernehme jetzt wieder im Wechsel natürlich mit Eva diese 2. Liga-Tour vom Rasenfunk. Und freue mich sehr, dass sie eingeschaltet hat. Wir reden heute zum einen über den SC Paderborn, aber auch über den SSV Ulm. Und das mache ich selbstverständlich nicht alleine. Über den SCP rede ich heute mit Ramona Kleibaumhüter. Grüß dich, Mona!
Hallo!
Willst du uns kurz was über deine Fansozialisierung erzählen, damit die Leute dich so ein bisschen greifen können? Warum haben wir dich eingeladen?
Ja, gerne. Also, ja, eingeladen habt ihr mich, ich sag mal indirekt, über den Padercast, muss man sagen. Also das ist der Podcast, den ich auch regelmäßig verfolge vom SC Paderborn. Und da sitzen vier liebe Jungs. Andreas, Marco, Kevin und Basti. Und den höre ich immer ganz fleißig. Und ja, von denen hatte leider keiner Zeit. Und ja, die haben mich dann vorgeschlagen, quasi einzuspringen. Also ich bin tatsächlich nicht irgendwie Sportjournalist oder ähnliches, sondern wirklich nur reiner Fan vom SC Paderborn, verfolge jedes Heimspiel durch eine Dauerkarte und fast auch jedes Auswärtsspiel im Stehblock. Und ja, das eigentlich fleißig seit 2017 ungefähr.
Allein das macht dich schon zur Expertin, da macht dich mal eine kleiner als du bist. Aber liebe Grüße natürlich an den Padercasts, von denen waren ja auch schon ein, zwei Menschen hier am Rasenfunk zu Gast. Und vielleicht ordnest du dich bald in dieses Portfolio ein. Wer auch glaube ich zum ersten Mal, natürlich zum ersten Mal wahrscheinlich dabei sein wird, ist Nadine Voigt von der Südwestpresse. Hi Nadine, wir reden heute über den SSV Ulm. Stell dich doch auch gerne kurz mal vor.
Ja, Nadine, Nadine Voigt, du hast schon angesprochen, ich bin Sportjournalistin, ich arbeite bei der Südwestpresse in Ulm als Sportreporterin, begleite jetzt den SSV tatsächlich schon meine sechste Saison. Und neben unserer, ich sage jetzt mal, multimedialen Berichterstattung, Print online und so weiter, haben wir seit einem Jahr auch einen Podcast, den Schwarzenfunk, in dem ich auch Moderatorin bin. Und ja, so kam ich ins Podcast-Geschäft, zeige ich jetzt mal.
Sehr gut. Und bevor wir weitermachen, natürlich auch der stetige Hinweis, dass der Rasenfunk werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei ist. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich über die Rasenfunk-UnterstützerInnen. Wenn ihr davon teil seid, ist das wunderbar. Wenn nicht, dann könnt ihr sehr gerne auf www.rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub alles weiter darüber erfahren. So, und bevor wir dann zum SCP-Paderborn und zum SSV Ulm kommen, wollen wir einmal über die allgemeine Lage der Liga reden. Auch in einer Länderspielpause bieten sich Themen natürlich an. Mona, auf was hast du denn so in der 2. Liga geblickt, was aktuell ganz spannend sein könnte?
Ja, die Liga an sich ist ja grundsätzlich immer spannend, finde ich. Also egal, welche Saison, egal, wer da auf und absteigt, es ist irgendwie laut vieler Experten dann in dem Jahr auch wieder die beste 2. Liga aller Zeiten. Und ich finde es halt so schön, dass da alles so eng ist. Also da kann ja wirklich jeder jeden schlagen. Und ja, so ein bisschen für mich kristallisiert sich wieder Elbersberg so ein bisschen als Überraschung raus muss ich sagen oder so ein bisschen als Angstgegner für einen Auswärtsfahrer. Da haben wir ja auch noch eine Rechnung offen aus dem letzten Jahr. Und ja, ansonsten muss ich tatsächlich auch sagen, hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, dass Schalke doch so weit unten ist. Also ich habe zwar damit gerechnet, dass es für die schwer wird, aber dass sie dann tatsächlich jetzt doch so weit unten stehen. Ja, hat mich überrascht.
Haben wir jetzt unter Kees von Wonderen zumindest ja die ersten drei Punkte holen können im letzten Spiel gegen Regensburg, ein 2 zu 0, das war aber auch der absolute Pflichtsieg und davor gegen Ulm ein 0 zu 0, ja, erkämpft. Ich glaube, ich erinnere mich richtig, Nadine, dass da Ulm die eigentlich bessere Mannschaft war, oder?
Ja, definitiv. Also das muss man so sagen. Aus Ulmers Sicht waren das drei, also waren es einfach zwei verlorene Punkte. Am Ende ist ein Punkt rausgesprungen, immerhin. Aber dann wäre deutlich mehr gegangen gegen Schalke.
Und zur engen Lage der Liga, das zeigt ja allein die, ich sag mal, obere Tabellenhälfte. Man ist mit 18 Punkten neunter, das ist aktuell Magdeburg, mit 17 Punkten elfter, das ist Hertha BSC. Und Hertha ist trotzdem nur 5 Punkte vom Tabellenplatz 1 von Hannover entfernt. Also es ist ultraeng und es ist wie so oft so, wie man in der Zweitliga sagt, du spielst entweder um den Aufstieg oder gegen den Abstieg. Aber was da zwischendrin gibt es eigentlich nicht so richtig. Nadine, hast du ein Thema mitgebracht, was dir in den letzten Tagen oder Wochen aufgefallen ist?
Ja, ich bin ja, du hast ja angeschrieben, ich bin ja auch neu in der Liga. Deswegen muss ich mich auch noch als Journalistin so ein bisschen in der Liga einfinden. Und ich blicke natürlich jetzt aus Ulmers Sicht, aber da reden wir ja nachher noch detaillierter drüber, vor allem aufs untere Tabellenende, sag ich jetzt mal. Und es ist natürlich schon vorfällig, dass die drei Aufsteiger hinten drin stehen mit Preußen Münster, Ulm und Regensburg. Und was ich da aber jetzt zuletzt schon besonders fand, war Preußen Münster, die es ja dann doch geschafft haben, gegen Düsseldorf zu gewinnen und auch im KSC ein 1 zu 1 abzutrotzen. Und das spricht so ein bisschen von meiner These, dass eben auch diese Ursteiger, diese Durchmarschierer, noch ein bisschen Zeit brauchen, um in dieser Liga auch anzukommen. Und ja, vielleicht noch ein Satz zu Regensburg, finde ich ganz, ganz schwierig einzuschätzen. Habt ihr letztes Jahr in der 3. Liga gesehen. Und ja, auch in der 3. Liga, sie haben ja einen sehr, sehr starken Start hingelegt gehabt und waren ja zur Winterpause mit Dynamo Dresden quasi, schon im L. Also dachte ich ja schon, das sind die sicheren Hochsteiger und am Ende sind dann doch Münster und Ulm quasi durchmarschiert. Und da finde ich es ganz eindrücklich, dass die eben diese Unkonstanz jetzt auch haben und an den Tag liegen. Dann gewinnen sie mal gegen Fürth im DFB-Pokal und verlieren dann jetzt aber auch wieder gegen Schalke. Also es ist so ein bisschen das, was Mona ja auch angesprochen hat. Und man mag es ja nicht glauben, es klingt ja auch abgetroschen, aber irgendwie kann dann doch jeder jeden schlagen.
Unter Idyriums-Trainer Andreas Patz zumindest ein bisschen besser unterwegs als davor unter Joe Enochs. Der musste ja nach dieser sagengewobenen 3 zu 8 Liederlage gegen Nürnberg seinen Platz räumen und unter Patz haben sie zumindest das Spiel gegen Elbersberg gewonnen, sind im Pokal gegen Fürth. Du hast es erwähnt, Nadine, weitergekommen. Klar, das 0 zu 2 gegen Schalke ist ärgerlich, aber immer noch deutlich bessere Bilanz als es davor der Fall war. Also vielleicht schiebt das den Konkurrenzkampf in der Abstiegszone noch ein bisschen enger zusammen. Sorgen vor der Mine bei Nadine und Ulm, aber mal gucken, wie das weitergeht. Ich habe auch ein Thema mitgebracht und ich war einer der Armseelen, die am Sonntag im CityCube des Messegelände Berlins da waren, beider 10 Stunden mit der Versammlung von Hertha BSC. Gut, ich muss gestehen, ich bin nach ungefähr 9 Stunden blutgedrungen gegangen, weil ich meinen Zug erwischen musste, aber trotzdem habe ich lange durchgehalten. Und diese Wahl ist ja auch– solche Vereinswahlen sind ja oft eher so ein Nischenthema. Bei Hertha BSC hatte man aber schon das Gefühl, dass da fast ein nationales Brennglas drauf war aufgrund des Erbes von Kai Bernstein. Und wie würde dieser Weg jetzt, dieser Berliner Weg weitergehen? Würde er weitergeführt werden? Würde ein anderer Kandidat gewinnen? Und das Kurzfazit ist, der Berliner Weg wird vom ja den quasi bewährten Person weitergeführt. Fabian Drescher hat mit über 80 Prozent diese Wahl gewonnen. Das war der sagenumwobene Erdrutsch-Sieg. Er war ja der Vizepräsident unter Kai Bernstein, dann der Interimspräsident seit Bernsteins Tod im Januar, hat dieses Projekt weitergeführt und hat dafür jetzt mehr oder weniger die Lorbeeren dann auch geerntet. Vizepräsidentin, die erste Vizepräsidentin in der Geschichte von RTBSC ist Anne Noske. Das ist eine Schlagzeile an sich schon wert, aber auch sie war vorher Teil des Präsidiums, also auch da ein bewährter Teil der vorjährigen Vereinsführung bleibt da auch erhalten. Spannend war diese MV allemal. Es gab eine Badehose, die auf der Bühne gezeigt wurde. Es gab einen verbrannten 50-Euro-Schein. Es gab einen sagenumwobenen Umschlag, der in den Millionen Investoren drinstecken sollten. Und das entpuppte sich als heiße Luft. Das alles nachzuerzählen wäre bitter. Und würde lange dauern. Ich verweise schamlos auf meinen eigenen Podcast HerthaBase, wo wir das Ganze lang und ausführlich erzählt haben. Also, wen das als Außenstehende interessiert, glaubt uns. Den Katastrophentourismus wollt ihr nicht verpassen. Es war wirklich skurril. Am Ende hat aber, glaube ich, der Kandidat auch gewonnen, der den ehrlichsten und besten Wahlkampf geführt hat. Und dieser ist jetzt auf vier Jahre erst mal bestätigt und hat natürlich große Aufgaben bei Hertha. Mit der Nordic-Bond-Anleihe 40 Millionen Euro werden November 2025 fällig. Mit einem Aufstieg, der möglichst in dieser Saison geschafft werden will, allerspätestens am besten in der nächsten Saison mit finanziellen Problemen und so weiter. Also da warten große Aufgaben auf das Präsidium und Fabian Drescher. Aber wie gesagt, lest euch da gerne einiges zu durch. Das war Wahnsinn. Allein auch die Rekordanzahl von 4000 Hertha-Mitgliedern, die an dem Tag waren. Da waren 3900 davon stimmberechtigt. Also, ja, es war eine breite Masse da. Um 15.40 Uhr waren die Würstchen alle. Wenig später gaben sich die Lieferanten die Klink in die Hand, weil plötzlich irgendwie Meter hoch Pizzen in den Saal getragen wurden. Es war sehr skurril. Dementsprechend, das wollte ich noch kurz nacherzählen, es war ein Fest, es waren alle Emotionen dabei. Und Fabian Drescher ist das neue alte Gesicht des EV bei Hertha BSC. So, dann haben wir das auch abgehandelt und wollen dementsprechend jetzt weiter im Text. Und weiter im Text bedeutet in dem Fall zum SCP-Paderborn. Mona, 21 Punkte nach 12 Spielen, Platz 2, nur ein Punkt hinter der Wellenführer Hannover. Wie blickt ein SCP-Fan bislang auf diese Saison?
Ja, recht zufrieden, würde ich sagen. Also, ist ja auf jeden Fall ein Tick besser als die Saison davor. Ich glaube, drei Punkte mehr als letzte Saison zum 12. Spieltag. Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich bin einer der Fans, die nicht aufsteigen möchte, auch wenn es finanziell natürlich immer gut ist für einen Verein. Aber ich finde die 2. Liga einfach geiler. Und dieses Spannende, und jedes Mal steigt jemand anders auf. Finde ich halt einfach schön, auch die ganzen Stadien, die ganzen Vereine, die da sind. Und ja, also ich bin sehr zufrieden auch mit der Arbeit von Weber und Quasenjog. Ich finde ihn unheimlich sympathisch, unseren Trainer. Wir haben ihn ja jetzt zumindest vertraglich noch bis 26, Sommer 26 gebunden. Aber gerne auch noch länger. Also ich genieße jede PK mit ihm, ob es jetzt vor dem Spiel oder nach dem Spiel ist. Ich finde ihn so schön ehrlich und menschlich und kann mir durch aufs Haus stellen, dass das ein großer Beitrag auch für den Erfolg ist. Einfach für diese Teamdynamik, also wie die sich untereinander verstehen. Ich habe auch den einen oder anderen Spieler bei Instagram abonniert, der dann einfach mal so einen Post loslässt nach einem Spieltag, wie geil dieses Team ist. Und das glaube ich denen tatsächlich auch. Und das spürt man halt auf dem Platz. Und es sind viele Junge dabei, gut durch ältere Abgänge, wie einen Conté oder einen Leiparz. Und dafür holt man halt entweder außer Jugendjemanden hoch, wie jetzt Engelns oder ein Castaneda. Und ich muss zugeben, ich bin überrascht, wie gut das teilweise funktioniert mit so jungen, gerade auch gegen Düsseldorf, dass man da einfach mal so ein Mittelfeld hinstellt, was irgendwie im Schnittgrad mal 20 ist, aber das trotzdem super hinkriegt. Also ich habe ein bisschen mit gerechnet, bin aber überrascht, dass es so gut funktioniert.
Das ist eine gute Mischung. Aber genau, das wäre nämlich meine Frage gewesen, ob man so einen bisherigen Saisonverlauf– ist ja noch nicht endgültig, aber nach einem Saisondrittel– solch einen Saisonverlauf hätte erwarten können, besonders eben mit dieser Transferperiode und diesem jungen Spielern. Also wenn man Thiago Scheller nennt, 22 in der Abwehr, Aaron Zehntner 20, Castañeda und Engels hast du genannt, 20 und 17, Ilias Ansar ist 20. Also was war denn die Erwartungshaltung für diese Saison? Gab es auch ein Saisonziel, was ausgerufen wurde?
Also, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ist das Saisonziel immer gleich oder besser als die Saison davor, meine ich. Und wir sind ja siebter geworden die Saison davor, war auch alles sehr eng oben und haben den einen oder anderen Punkt liegen lassen, was wir jetzt auch schon haben. Aber ja, also man hält sich da ja bei uns immer sehr zurück, auch mit dem Thema Aufstieg. Bügelt Lukas ja auch in jeder PK ab, wenn das schon jemand zur Sprache bringt. Aber ja, also wie gesagt, es ist erfolgreicher als ich dachte. Ich konnte es schwer einschätzen, wirklich auch durch diese ganzen Jungen. Wir haben ja schon immer eher in den unteren Ligen wie Regionalliga oder bei unserer eigenen zweiten, die er jetzt zweite Saison Regionalliga spielt, sag mal gewildert und das weiß man immer nicht so, wie das funktioniert. Also sehr große Hoffnung hat mir die Rückkehr von einem Sven Michel gemacht. Ja. Und auch wenn er selbst nur in Anführungszeichen gerade mal zwei Tore geschlossen hat, wenn es auch wichtige gegen Köln war, aber er ist halt auch irgendwie so einer der Erfahrungen und Stabilität reinbringt und diese Mischung finde ich halt auch gut, dass es nicht nur Junge sind oder nur Alte, sondern dass man auch so einen Grimaldi da hat und einen Michel, der da ja ein bisschen Routine auch reinbringt.
Bei Sven Michel muss ich immer an einen wunderbaren Artikel aus der 11 Freunde denken, wo er zu seinem Hobby befragt und begleitet wurde, denn er ist anscheinend ja Naturbursche und wird auch, glaube ich, irgendwie Kräutermichel oder so in der Mannschaft genannt, weil er gerne Pilz zusammengeht und seinen eigenen Garten hat. Und da ist er auch sehr untypisch für den modernen Fußball Profi agiert. Das fand ich immer sehr sympathisch, muss ich sagen.
Absolut. Also ich glaube, es gab sogar mal so eine Videoreihe mit ihm und ich glaube, es war Robert. Bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher, wo die dann tatsächlich auch wie so einen Gartenblock gemacht haben und bei ihm dann da waren. Und ich glaube, Angeln geht er auch gerne. Also sehr bodenständig und naturnah und mit Duftetyp.
Definitiv. Paderborn hat erst ein Ligaspiel verloren, habe ich in der Recherche gesehen. Das ist krass. Hat dazu, also hat noch 6 Unentschieden geholt. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, natürlich hätte man lieber die 3 Punkte. Aber wieso ist es denn so schwer, den SCP zu knacken? Hast du dafür einen Ansatz?
Also ich glaube, Lukas ist echt ein guter Taktiker. Also wie ich schon mal sagte, ich genieße echt die PKs mit ihm. Ich habe das Gefühl, der hat so einen Sachverstand dahinter und kann das aber auch fast immer auf die Mannschaft transportieren. Und früher, bevor er da war, auch noch mit Steffen Baumgart, da wusste man manchmal nicht, wenn die erste Halbzeit, sag ich mal, nicht so doll war, oh Gott, wird das noch was in der zweiten? Und bei Lukas ist das, finde ich, dass es manchmal richtig unterschiedliche Halbzeiten sein können. Selbst wenn die erste Halbzeit Mist war, hast du bei einem 2.0 Rückstand immer noch das Gefühl, das könnte noch was werden. Das war früher anders. Ich glaube, er bereitet sich da unheimlich intensiv darauf vor, ob das jetzt er ist oder sein Trainerteam oder wie auch immer, und hackt da echt taktisch einiges in der Hinterhand und kann auf viel reagieren. Das funktioniert nicht immer, aber recht oft, finde ich. Und das ist für meine Ansicht nach ein großer Beitrag, der uns da oben auch stehen lässt.
Ich hatte auch immer das Gefühl, wenn man zwei Dinge an Lukas Kwasniak so ein bisschen schätzt, dann ist es zum einen neu deutsch das Ingame-Coaching, wie du gesagt hast, wie er in Spielen reagiert, aber auch, wie er sich auf den Gegner einstellen kann. Das habe ich am ersten Spieltag live im Stadion gegen Hertha BSC auch gesehen. Das war unglaublich schwierig für Hertha gegen Paderborn, irgendwie Stiche zu setzen. Und man wurde dann ja auch relativ eiskalt durch, weiß ich nicht mehr, ein Eckball und ein Konter oder so, dann auch einfach dann geschlagen. Und das war schmucklos, aber das war richtig effizient und hatte sehr viel Hand und Fuß und sollte das ja dann im weiteren Saisonverlauf bestätigen. Aber dann reden wir nochmal ein bisschen über Trainer Lukas Kwasniak. Der ist jetzt seit Sommer 2021 im Amt, hat das übrigens dann gemeinsam mit Thomas Wörle, wie ich gesehen habe. Beide dementsprechend auch schon lange im Amt. Paderborn wurde unter ihm 7. 7. und steht jetzt auf Rang 2. Du hast schon ein bisschen was zu ihm ausgeführt, aber vielleicht kannst du seine Zeit bei Paderborn vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen und dann vielleicht auch die Frage beantworten, warum er sich denn so lange hält und für welchen Fußball er auch stehen will.
Ja, gute Frage. Also ich denke, er hat sich genauso, wie er das mit den Spielern macht, bei uns natürlich auch entwickelt. Ich glaube, er versteht sich sehr gut mit Benjamin Weber. Weber ist ja auch so ein Mensch zumindest. Er war mal bei einem Padercast auch zu Gast. Empfehle ich sehr, die Folge sich da mal das anzuhören, wo er auch so ein bisschen seine Idee erklärt hat, dass er sehr auf die Jugendarbeit setzt. Also er will die Kinder der Umgebung, sage ich mal, entwickeln und bei uns zu Profis machen. Also nicht immer nur schauen, wo kann ich gut was einkaufen oder Ablöse frei holen, sondern wirklich, klingt jetzt blöd, aber selbst heranzüchten, hat ja bei einem Engels bisher, finde ich, ganz gut funktioniert, wie man sieht, oder einem Ansager. Und ich glaube, davon ist auch Lukas überzeugt, dass er die auch begleiten will. Also nicht einfach immer nur, wo man manchmal früher so den Eindruck hatte, Geld durch einen guten Transfer verdienen. Klar, das will ein Verein immer noch, aber die natürlich auch selber ausbilden und dann nutzen und klar ist irgendwann das Ziel. Liga gehe ich jetzt mal von aus, welcher Verein will das nicht schon finanziell. Aber ich glaube dann auf einer vernünftigen Grundlage. Also ich sehe keinen Sinn darin, aufzusteigen, das Geld mitzunehmen und dann, ich sage mal, die Hucke vollzukriegen und wieder runter. Und ich glaube, das will Lukas auch nicht. Also ich glaube, Lukas ist ehrgeizig, aber realistisch dabei. Und ich glaube, er liebt diesen Verein. Zumindest habe ich diesen Eindruck, wenn man da von Liebe sprechen kann. Also große Sympathien. Ich glaube, er fühlt sich hier wohl. Er hat den Rückhalt. Das hat Steffen Baumgart schon bei Paderborn, dass ihm da nicht groß rein geredet wurde oder er viel seiner Ideen umsetzen konnte und nicht auf einem wackeligen Stuhl saß oder jetzt Lukas sitzt, sondern auch mal eine, ja, eine schlechtere Serie ohne Siege, wie wir sie auch letzte Saison haben, hatten Aushält und ich glaube, das schätzt man als Trainer und spielt dann quasi alles so zusammen, dass es passt.
Was mir in der Recherche aufgefallen ist, als ich mich so ein bisschen durch die Statistiken gebolzt habe, bei den Laufwerten. Man ist bei der Laufdistance auf Platz 1 in der Liga, bei den Sprints auf Platz 2 und bei den intensiven Läufen auf Platz 1. Das ist ja irre. Hat das Paderborn in den letzten Jahren auch schon ausgezeichnet, dieser, diese Intensität, dieser Kampf? Und ich schließe an, gleichzeitig hat man aber auch 53 Prozent Ballbesitz und ist damit Platz 3 in der Liga. Also quasi ja verlangt offensichtlich dann ja auch von seinen Spielern sehr viel ab, wenn man mit dem Ball was kann, aber gleichzeitig auch so viel laufen muss.
Ja, also Laufintensität hat ja unter Steffen schon angefangen, sage ich mal, dass er da auch viel verlangt hat und und bewegen und ich meine, das merkt man auch, wenn man sich, wie du sagtest, auch durch Statistiken wühlt, wenn wir nicht diese Laufbereitschaft hatten in Spielen. Also ich glaube, wir haben im Schnitt, was haben wir, 118 oder 119 Kilometer, glaube ich, pro Spiel. Und wenn es dann aber mal so vier, fünf weniger sind, dann war das auch meist kein Sieg oder kein zufriedenstellendes Spiel vom Gesamtablauf. Und da verlangt er halt die Intensität und er ist auch keiner, der so dieses einfach rauspölen, sondern es soll halt schon alles so ein bisschen überlegt sein. Ich finde, es sieht manchmal– und ja, da reg ich mich manchmal als Fan im Stadion dann auch auf– sieht es so ein bisschen aus wie beim Handball. So links, rechts, links, rechts, vor der Mittellinie hin und her gepasst. Dann hat man natürlich auch viele Pässe, viel Ballbesitz.
Der Linanen ist das früher unter Paldada hinten rumscheiße.
Kann man so sagen, ja. Aber da steckt dann natürlich auch ein bisschen immer was hinter. Und das ist ja nicht sinnlos. Und der Erfolg gibt ihm ja und der Mannschaft auch aktuell noch recht.
Nadine, da hole ich dich mal kurz rein, denn Ulm ist in der Laufdistance auf Platz 2. Also dementsprechend ähnlich intensiv unterwegs. Erkennst du darin, was Mona erzählt, erkennst du darin auch ein bisschen Thomas Wörle? Oder greife ich da zu weit?
Würde ich schon sagen. Also ich hatte jetzt die aktuelle Statistik nicht im Kopf. Ich dachte, Ulm wäre sogar noch auf Platz 1, weil ich glaube, das war uns in meiner Zeit. Aber ja, also auch diese hohe Intensität, die zum Beispiel Mona ja gerade auch genannt hat, also das ist auf jeden Fall was, was auch Thomas Wörle von seinen Spielern fordert. Es spielen auch so ein bisschen andere Thematiken mit rein. Also auch wenn man jetzt auf den Ulmer Kader blickt, dann ist es natürlich, also Marktwert, Qualität usw., sind so Fragen, die sich auch stellen. Also das heißt, man muss auch über diese hohen Laufwerte einiges ausgleichen, aber trotzdem gehört es schon auch so zu den Grundzügen, die Thomas Wörle von seinen Spielern fordert.
Ich habe noch eine Parallele entdeckt und das ist eben auch ein bisschen die Transferstrategie. Ich habe die jungen Spieler, die jungen Wilden bei Paderborn schon genannt. Bei Ulm fand ich es sehr spannend. Jetzt steigt man auf, ist das erst mal seit über 20 Jahren in der 2. Liga. Niemand in diesem Kader kennt gefühlt diese Liga. Man entscheidet sich dazu, Spieler wie Maurice Krattenmacher 19, Laurin Ulrich 19, Aaron Keller 20 oder auch Alexander Kavic 20 zu holen. Also sehr junge Talente. Wurde das mal aufgegriffen, warum man sich für den Weg entschieden hat und nicht die alten Recken geholt hat?
Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, so zwei Gedanken. Also zum einen ist natürlich eine finanzielle Sache auf jeden Fall in Ulm. Also der Kaderspieleretat liegt zum Beispiel zwischen 8 bis 10 Millionen. Und die Spieler, die du jetzt aufgezählt hast, bis auf Alexander Kavits, sind alle ausgeliehen. Also Kartenmacher, jetzt Bayern-Profi sozusagen, hat im Sommer bei Bayern unterschrieben, wurde dann nach Ulm ausgeliehen. Keller auch von Unterhach hingekommen. Und das war aber schon so der eingeschlagene Weg. Also man wollte dieses Grundgerüchte der Mannschaft, die auch in der 3. Liga und auch schon in der Regionalliga so zusammengespielt hat, auf jeden Fall halten. Und aus diesem Grundgerücht heraus entwickeln. Und das eben vor allem mit jungen und betat hungrigen Spielern.
Kommen wir zurück zu Paderborn. Von nicht so langer Zeit ist ja Fabian Wohlgemuth dann zum Pau für Stuttgart gewechselt. Leiste dort offensichtlich auch sehr gute Arbeit. Ist, glaube ich, ja sogar schon aufgestiegen. Und das hat ja dann Benjamin Weber, lustigerweise hat ja Hertha auch einen Sportdirektor, der Benjamin Weber heißt. Das ist sehr verwirrend. Hat den ja mehr oder weniger ein Spiel gemacht. Der kam im Januar 23, was ich interessant fand, als Videoanalyst quasi vom FC Chelsea. Und der FC Chelsea ja auch ein Verein, der trotz vier Millionen ja sehr auf die Jugend setzt. Wie würdest du sagen, hat er sich bei Paderborn eingefügt? Du hast schon den Podcast beim Padercast erwähnt, die Folge, die ja dabei war. Wie nimmst du seine Arbeit wahr?
Auf jeden Fall sehr positiv. Also man merkt halt auch, dass, wie gesagt, vom Fach kommt, sage ich mal, Chelsea. Ich glaube, Paris Saint-Germain war ja, glaube ich, auch. Ich habe mich eh schon mal gefragt, wie wir an den herangekommen sind, aber es soll mir egal sein, jetzt wo er bei uns so eine gute Arbeit leistet. Aber, ja, also ich denke, er holt die ran. Aber dieses Zusammenspiel auch mit Lukas, dass sie dann auch eine Chance bekommen. Und dass auch irgendwie jeder das Gefühl hat, wenn er gute Arbeit leistet, auch durchaus in der ersten eine Chance zu bekommen. Und das auch jetzt wie bei Engels zum Beispiel mit 17. Also er hat auch mal gesagt, er fühlt sich hier wohl, genauso wie Lukas. Und ich glaube, er hat da auch nicht so das enge Korsett. Und wenn der Erfolg ihm dann auch noch Recht gibt und er weiter so die Arbeit leisten kann, die er macht, habe ich da auch keine Bedenken für die nächste Saison. Ich bin gespannt, ob sich zum Winter-Transfer-Fenster noch irgendwas ergibt. Also ich habe noch gar nichts gehört im Punkte, Gerüchten oder Ähnliches. Ich hoffe, dass ein Aaron Zehntner bei uns bleibt, der ja auch sehr jung ist, Un-Nationalspieler. Weil bei ihm merkt man es schon. Also die zwei Spiele, die er nicht da war, krankheitsbedingt oder verletzungsbedingt, die waren schon schwer. Also den zu ersetzen, würde ich ungern wollen oder müssen wollen.
Im Sommer hat man ja mit Kai Klefisch und Charlotte Conte zwei Stammstieler verloren. Ich glaube, Klefisch konnte man auch wirklich zum Leistungsträger auf jeden Fall erklären. Der war ja wirklich gut bei Paderborn, hat, wie du schon beschrieben hast, viele junge Spieler geholt, natürlich auch einen Sven Michel zurückgeholt oder auch einen Luca Herrmann ist jetzt nicht so jung mit 25. Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, dass man keinen Mittelstürmer Klassischen verpflichtet hat und dementsprechend ja auf Constance und Grimaldi vertraut, beide aber nicht so richtig zünden. Ist das ein Thema an Paderborn, die Sturmspitze?
Constance, ja. Also zumindest nimmt man es unter den Fans oder Social Media, wobei da ja meist die Trolle eher ihren Blödsinn äußern als die anderen. Schon wahr, dass man sich da eigentlich mehr von ihm erhofft. Es hatte natürlich auch das Pech, dass er dann die eine oder andere Szene immer dabei hatte, wo er nicht getroffen hat. Schwierig, also ich kann ihn auch noch nicht so so richtig greifen. Also Grimaldi für mich ganz klar eine Person, die wir brauchen schon allein von der Körperlichkeit. Wenn ich das mit anderen vergleiche, also man merkt, wenn er spielt, dann haben wir einen Spieler auf dem Platz, der vorne die Bälle festmachen kann, den man halt nicht mal eben umreißt oder der auch mit dem Kopf was kann. Ja, ich habe die letzte Saison mehr getroffen. Klar, wenn ich das jetzt an den Treffern festmache, dann ist er noch nicht so gezündet diese Saison, aber ich finde ihn trotzdem aufgrund allein seiner Körperlichkeit unheimlich wichtig bei uns.
Zeigt sich auch daran, dass er immerhin schon zwei Tore vorgelegt hat. Also dann schafft er ja anscheinend doch irgendwie Raum und Platz für seine Mitspieler. Was ich auch spannend jetzt fand im Saisonverlauf, ich glaube, man ist mit Pelle Böwink angefangen in der Saison im Tor. Er stand zunächst im Kasten und mittlerweile ist es aber Markus Schubert. Wie ist das passiert und wie hat das quasi auch erklärt? Und wie macht sich Schubert bislang?
Ja, richtig. Also wir haben mit Pelle gestartet. Grundsätzlich verlangt Jukas immer von den Torehütern auch, dass sie mitspielen, also dass sie die Bälle halt nicht wegschlagen sollen und halt auch mal den kurzen Pass und sich anbieten sollen. Und das ist halt bei Pelle bei dem ein oder anderen Spiel halt in die Hose gegangen. Unter anderem auch gegen Kaiserslautern bei dem einen Abendspiel, wodurch die dann in Führung gegangen sind. Ich glaube, Tachi war es. Ja, und dann war es das eine Spiel dann zu viel. Und seitdem steht halt Schubert, der eigentlich erst zum Pokalspiel reinkommen sollte, zwischen den Pfosten. Er macht einen guten Job. Bisher ist er allerdings jetzt auch noch nicht so geprüft worden. Pelle war ja erst drei Spiele drin. Ja, ich kann es nachvollziehen, aber ich muss zugeben, ich fand die Art und Weise in den Interviews nicht so schön. Das war schon so ein, ja, wie Lukas sich da geäußert hat. Das fand ich ein bisschen befremdlich, fand ich schade. Das ist jetzt eigentlich auch vergessen, aber da hatte man teilweise das Gefühl, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er es sogar wörtlich gesagt hat, dass Pelle gar nichts gehalten hat, das fand ich ein bisschen ungerecht. Vielleicht war da vorher ein Gespräch, keine Ahnung, oder es ist irgendwie so rausgerutscht, wobei er es zwei, drei Mal in unterschiedlichen Interviews erwähnt hat. Weil Pelle hat für mich gut gehalten. Also auch die Statistik, da war glaube ich oberes Drittel oder Mittelfeld. Also er war jetzt nicht grottig und der Schlechteste der 2. Liga. Aber er hat sich halt zu viel geleistet, wodurch jetzt halt Schubert eine Chance bekommt. Und Lukas ja auch gesagt hat, dass er jetzt unsere neue Nummer 1 ist.
Ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass quasi ohnehin ja jemand ist, der dann auch schon mal echt Nägel mit Köpfen macht bei Personalien. Ich meine, war es nicht auch Janis Huth im Tor, der auch mal quasi rasiert wurde während der Saison und wo auch zu ihm, aber auch anderen Profis sehr harsche Worte gefallen sind im Sinne von Paderborn kann es sich nicht leisten, satte Spieler zu haben und dann sollen sie halt gehen. Und ich meine, dass ich da mal was mitbekommen habe.
Ja, tatsächlich ja. Also das war das berühmte Elbersberg-Spiel auswärts, wo ich sagte, da haben wir noch eine Rechnung offen, wo wir 4-0 weggeklatscht wurden auf gut Deutsch. Das war das nie-lichste Spiel, was ich seit langem gesehen habe. Ja, und vor allem in Elbersberg. Nee, aber danach tatsächlich war Huth weg. Und er war ja sogar unser Kapitän zu der Zeit. Also so ein bisschen eine und halb bis doppel Strafe. Und ja, also ich glaube auch, wenn man seine Chance bei Lukas bekommt, also es ist nicht Hopp oder Topp, aber wenn es dann eine zu viel ist und das Tröpfchen, was das fast zum Überlaufen bringt, dann ist es glaube ich auch schwer, da wieder den Fuß in die Tür zu bekommen. Also wird glaube ich nicht einfach für Pelle, wenn Schubert sich nicht verletzt oder gleiche Böcke fallen lässt. Ich meine gut, wir haben jetzt den kleinsten unserer Torhüter im Tor, aber mein Gott, die paar Zentimeter. Bisher macht er, wie gesagt, einen guten Job.
Jan Sommer zeigt ja, dass es nicht so wichtig ist, vielleicht, wie groß man ist, sondern das muss man noch ausgleichen. Die Diskussion kommt immer nur auf, wenn es dann nicht ganz klappt. Vorher sind immer alle zufrieden. Jetzt haben wir über junge Spieler geredet und auch vielleicht über die eine oder andere Baustelle. Wer sind denn so die Leistungsträger bei Paderborn? Wer darf sich auf gar keinen Fall verletzen? Ansonsten wird es richtig düster.
Richtig düster glaube ich jetzt nicht so, wobei ich, wie ich eben schon sagte, da schon wirklich Aaron Zehnta auf eins setzen würde, wo man es am deutlichsten merkt tatsächlich, wenn er fehlt. Weil er ist halt schnell, er läuft auch viel auf seiner linken Seite, spielt hat auch Pässe. In Standards ist er super, sei es jetzt Freistoß oder Eckball. Also der tut schon am meisten weh. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, wahrscheinlich einen Götze hinten, weil der für wirklich stabil ist und das da zusammenhält.
Aaron Zehnta steht auch schon bei fünf Torvorlagen. Das ist schon beeindruckend.
Ja.
So, ich habe es vorhin, um die Schleife zu finden, ja auch schon erwähnt, 21 Punkte nach 12 Spielen, Platz 2. Was ist denn jetzt gemessen daran, das Saisonziel für die verbliebenen Zweidrittel der Saison? Und wo will Paderborn darüber hinaus mittelfristig hin? Gibt es da so Ziele? Oft hört man von Zweitliga-Vereinen ja, man will Top 25 Deutschland sein oder so. Gibt es da Ähnliches mit Paderborn? Ja, ja, alles klar.
Ich weiß schon. Ja, genau, das haben wir auch mal gesagt. Top 20 oder ob es jetzt Top 25 war, weiß ich nicht. Also das Wort Aufstieg nimmt man auch erst in den Mund, wenn man es wahrscheinlich eh kaum noch verlieren kann oder so drei Spieltage vor Schluss mit zehn Punkten Vorsprung. Also da wird sich auch Lukas sehr spät äußern. Also Saisonziel ist auf jeden Fall, denke ich, immer die Punktzahl, die man davor die Saison hat. Ich glaube, 57 hatten wir, dass man so um den Dreh ist und möglichst die gleiche oder bessere Platzierung. Und alles on top wäre natürlich nett.
Gibt es derzeit irgendwelche Themen außerhalb des Platzes, die Paderborn beschäftigen? Wirtschaftlicher Natur, Fan-Natur oder ist gerade alles ruhig und man konzentriert sich einfach aufs Sportliche?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, es ist relativ ruhig. Es schweht so ein bisschen, denke ich mal, in der Kommunikation zwischen aktiver Fanszene und Verein. Da ist halt in der letzten Zeit nicht besonders geschickt reagiert worden.
Kannst du sagen, kannst du das kurz ausführen an einem Beispiel?
Ja, also so ein bisschen Start war, glaube ich, mitunter. Also es ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung. Ich habe keine Kontakte irgendwie zu aktiven Fanszene oder ähnliches. Aber wenn man so ein bisschen Social Media verfolgt oder auch im Padercast, wo wir untereinander auch chatten können, die Zuhörer, dass das so ein bisschen das Braunschweig-Spiel auswärts war. Da ist halt auf dem Bahnhof was vorgefallen, als wir nach Hause fahren sollten, dass die Polizei halt mit Tränengas etc. in die Menge, wo auch Kinder und alte Leute waren. Erwähnt man ja immer gerne diese beiden Gruppen, weil die ein bisschen schützenswerter sind und uns Braunschweig-Fans geholfen haben, Außenstehende geholfen haben. Und ob es jetzt die Fans von Braunschweig waren, die der Fan, das ist nicht der Beirat, wie nennt man das denn, die da immer mitfahren und auch Ansprechpartner sind.
Fan-Hilfen.
Fan-Hilfen, genau. Fan-Hilfe von Braunschweig, Fan-Hilfe von Paderborn. Also egal, wen man gefragt hat, hat halt jeder gesagt, wir haben keine Aggression wahrgenommen von Paderborn-Fans. Da ist nichts vorgefallen. Es war die Polizei. Und man hat da irgendwie sich dann, die letzte Äußerung war dann halt, ja, wir warten ab, was da offiziell kommt oder von der Polizei. Und dann wurde da aber nie wieder was zugesagt. Oder beim Hamburg-Spiel, das im Winter letzten Jahres, als dann quasi Eisschollen von oben auf uns geworfen wurden und teilweise dann Leute da blutüberströmend waren. Also man hat halt immer das Gefühl, wenn es irgendwo Pyro- oder die Gäste-Fans betrifft, dann wird immer gleich in Social-Media-Hilfen gepostet und angeboten, etc. Aber wenn es die eigenen Fans betrifft, dann ist da so ein bisschen Schweigen im Walde. Und ja, weiß ich nicht, dass man dann irgendwelche Choreos verbieten wollte, als zum Beispiel Uwe Hünemeyer sein Abschiedsspiel hatte. Da hatte die Fans in eine riesige Choreo über den ganzen Süd vorbereitet, die dann verboten werden sollte, weil, glaube ich, pyrotechnisch was vorgefallen war. Es sind immer so Kleinigkeiten. Und da hat man das Gefühl, da ist im Moment so ein bisschen die Kommunikation gestört. Ja, das würde ich mir wünschen, dass sich das mal wieder bessert. Plus halt auf einer Mitgliederversammlung, dass es keine Rabatte mehr gibt für Mitglieder bei Dauerkarten mit einer Begründung, die aber keiner verstehen kann, weil andere Vereine es weiterhin machen, dass man sagt, als Mitglied kriegt man zum Beispiel 10 oder 15 Prozent. Aber es sind so viele Kleinigkeiten, die zusammen spielen. Und da bin ich mal auf die nächste Jahreshauptversammlung, die ist bei uns meist so Januar, Februar gespannt, was da noch kommt.
Dann schauen wir uns das in Zukunft noch mal an. Bis dahin vielen lieben Dank Mona und schalte dich aber natürlich gerne ein, wenn dich zu Ulm etwas interessiert oder du nachhaken möchtest, dann gerne. Du bist hier gar nicht außen vor. Aber dann kommen wir zum SSV Ulm, quasi gespiegelt in der Tabelle, der vorletzte Tabellenplatz aktuell in der 2. Liga. Darum soll es aber erst mal noch nicht gehen, Nadine. Vorher hast du die mühevolle Aufgabe, uns den Wahnsinn der letzten Jahre in Ulm zu erklären. Wie ist es denn gelungen, zweimal in Folge aufzusteigen, also vom direkten Wege aus, von der Regionalliga in die 2. Liga, wo man zuletzt in der Saison 2000, 2001 war?
Ja, das jetzt mal ganz kurz auszuführen, ist natürlich schwierig, aber das Stichwort Wahnsinn trifft es ganz gut. Das war übrigens auch ein Motto, das die Fans dann ausgerufen haben, dass es so in der 3. Liga der absolute Wahnsinn ist. Das war eine Anspielung auf den letzten großen Höhenflug des SSV Ulm. Hat ja schon bei Bundesliga gespielt, 1999, 2000. Damals, der SSV ja tatsächlich auch durchmarschiert, also vor 25 Jahren unter Ralf Rangnick und Martin Andermatt. Ralf Rangnick hat damals ja den Grundstein gelegt. Er hat sich dann im 2. Liga-Saison aber verabschiedet Richtung Stuttgart. Martin Andermatt hat übernommen, Ulm ist in die Bundesliga aufgestiegen. Das war so der große Höhenflug und ja, da muss man leider sagen, krachend gescheitert. Also folgte dann so ein Tiefschlag, es ging nochmal noch bis dann runter in die 2. Liga, also 2000, 2001 und daraufhin folgte dann die erste von drei Insolvenzen. Das heißt, also Ulm hat da dann schon eine relativ bewegte Vergangenheit hinter sich und sind zeitlich dann auch mal tatsächlich auch vom Aus gestanden, also nach der dritten Insolvenz, die war 2014, 15 und da hat dann der Wiederaufbau stattgefunden und die damaligen Verantwortlichen standen dann tatsächlich vor der Frage, ja, machen sie jetzt hier quasi, drehen sie den Schlüssel ins Schloss, also schließen sie die Türe ab und lassen den Fußballverein einfach begraben, in Anführungszeichen, oder wollen sie hier wieder was aufbauen und haben sich dann zu diesem, also jetzt nachher einen richtigen Schritt entschieden und versucht wieder was aufzubauen. So, das ist jetzt 9 Jahre her und das Ziel damals war schon, oder der Blick damals war schon, dass man den Schritt zurück in den Profifußball schaffen will, was langersehend dann auch war und ja, wie kam es dazu? Ich glaube, ein ganz einschneidendes Datum ist Juli 2021. Du hast vorhin auch schon angesprochen, da hat Lukas Krasniok, aber auch Thomas Wöhrle das Traineramt in Ulm übernommen, gleichzeitig auch als Stile-Geschäftsführer. Da kam relativ viel zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, am richtigen Ort zusammen. Und Thomas Wöhrle hat dann als Trainer, als die Vizemeisterschaft der Regionalliga Südwest erreicht, musste damals auch Elvis Park den Vortritt lassen. Und in seinem zweiten Jahr, in seinem zweiten Ressort, ist SSV dann in die 3. Liga aufgestiegen und das Vortritt wieder durchmassiert.
Dann kommen wir natürlich zu Thomas Wöhrle, den du eben erwähnt hast. Er ist natürlich der zentrale Faktor, neben Leuten, die natürlich immer im Stillen auch ihre gute Arbeit machen, ist der Trainer natürlich der, der dann auch im Fokus steht. Was zeichnet den 42-Jährigen denn aus? Für welchen Fußball steht er? Wie konnte er die Region und diesen Verein wieder so anzünden?
Ja, also was ihn auszeichnet ist auf jeden Fall, dass er sehr ruhige, sehr empathische und auch sympathische Art hat. Also er ist jetzt nicht der, der ich sage jetzt mal große Töne spuckt. Oder ich glaube, in der vorigen Folge wurde ja auch in die Personalie Alexander Zorniger besprochen. Also von Thomas Wörle würde nie öffentlich Kritik an seinen Tönen kommen. Nie, das macht er nicht. Also er steht absolut vor seiner Mannschaft. Und das ist schon auch ein wichtiger Punkt. Also diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, die der SSV in den Park legt und die er jetzt auch in der 2. Liga in den Park legt, ist eine große Stärke und eine sehr, sehr große Bedienstung von Thomas Wörle. Und dazu muss man vielleicht auch noch sagen, Thomas Wörle hatte am Anfang in Ulm ja auch nicht einen ganz einfachen Stand, sag ich jetzt mal. Er hat ja neun Jahre lang erfolgreich die Frauen des FC Bayern trainiert, hat damals den Trainer-Job, sein allererster Trainer-Job, auf dem er seine aktive Karriere aufgeben musste, beenden musste, von seinem Vater übernommen. Also das ist ja Familie Wörle, das ist ja eine richtige Fußballerfamilie, auch die Schwester damals Profifußballerin gewesen. Und ich sag mal so, also den Ulm-Brah ist auch nicht nur auf Begeisterung, das ist dann halt plötzlich hier, auch gut schwäbisch gesagt, da kommt jetzt einer, der hat bisher nur die Frauen trainiert. War völlig aus der Zeit gefallen, aber leider immer noch.
Also musste er da viele Ressentiments irgendwie erst mal tacklen.
Ja, also er hat auch mal gesagt, er musste aus einer großen Skepsis quasi eine kleinere werden lassen. Also er hatte schon auch das Gefühl, dass er sich da beweisen musste. Und er hatte auch, bevor er in Ulm Cheftrainer wurde, schon auch die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es gar nicht so einfach ist, dass seine Bewerbung oder auf dem Zettel von Vereinen zu landen, wenn man bisher im Innerbereich einfach noch keine Erfahrung hatte.
Ich sehe da fast auch so eine Art Pionier. Denn wenn ich mal darüber nachdenke, gibt es gar nicht so die großen Namen, die zwischen den beiden Verbänden quasi herumgewechselt sind. Ich denke gerade drüber nach. Nee, ehrlich gesagt fällt mir nicht viel ein, da ist Thomas Wörle dann doch schon jemand, der vielleicht einen gewissen Weg auch freischlägt. Es ist ja vielleicht dann auch so, dass man sieht, dass es eben überhaupt nichts bedeuten muss, ob man jetzt Männer oder Frauen trainiert, was ja de facto auch so ist. Aber wie wir eben festgestellt haben, gibt es Leute, die dann trotzdem irgendwelche Vorurteile haben oder ähnliches. Der Verein hat vergangene Woche verkündet, dass Wörle seinen Auslauf im Vertrag bis 2027 verlängert hat. Ich nehme mir jetzt mal ganz stark an, dass wenige daran zweifeln, dass das die richtige Entscheidung ist.
Ja, das kann man, glaube ich, einfach auch so unterschreiben. Also es war, ich würde sagen, unerwartet, weil aus dem Sinne, dass der SSV in der Vergangenheit doch sehr zögerlich mit Vertragsverlängerungen umgegangen ist. Natürlich spielten da auch die vergangenen Saisons mit rein, wo man da letztlich auch nicht wusste, in welcher Liga spielt man und so weiter. Also vielleicht auch von beiden Parteien aus hat sich relativ lange immer rausgezögert. Und ja, jetzt diesen Schritt zu gehen zur Länderspielpause, wo man da steht, wo man steht, mit zehn Punkten vornetschter in der Tabelle, ist schon ein wichtiger Schritt und zeigt absolut, also Geschäftsführer Christyle hat das so auch gesagt, man will den gemeinsamen Weg weitergehen, man will auf Ruhe, Kontinuität und Zusammenhalt setzen. Und das zeigt schon auch sehr, dass der SSV da unwirrt auf seinen Weg weitergeht und sich da nicht von irgendwelchen äußeren Faktoren oder so bestören lässt. Und natürlich ist es auch ein großer, ich habe ein großes Signal auch jetzt zu sagen, verlängert mein Trainer und mein verlängert mein Trainer-Team, dazu zählt auch, will ich auch ganz kurz erwähnen, Michael Kremens, der Chef-Scout, 29 Jahre jung, musste seine Karriere auch früh beenden, hat, glaube ich, eine U23 von Köln lange gespielt, mit dem er zum Beispiel auch verlängert hat. Also dieses Team, das jetzt seit Sommer 2021 so zusammenarbeitet wird oder soll perspektivisch auch weitere Jahre so zusammenarbeiten, das finde ich schon sehr, sehr stark, ist klar.
Definitiv. Dann kommen wir auch zur laufenden Spielzeit. Du hast eine Kennzahl schon genannt. 10 Punkte nach 12 Spielen auf dem Konto. Damit ist man Tabellenvorletzter, hat aber auch nur drei Punkte Schlagdistance auf Rang 13. Also Vorletzter klingt erst mal so dramatisch, aber wir haben ja das enge Teilnehmerfeld in der 2. Liga schon erwähnt. Wie würdest du denn jetzt dieses erste Saisondrittel bewerten? Was läuft gut und was fehlt noch, um weiter oben stehen zu können?
Ja, also es war natürlich jetzt mal ganz neu betrachtet einfach ein schlechter Saisonstart. Wenn man jetzt wieder das mit einbezieht, dass es sich natürlich um einen Aufsteiger handelt und so weiter, also ist das schon in Ordnung. Also man hat den Anschluss, das hast du angesprochen, auch ins untere Tabellenmittefeld, sag ich jetzt mal. Was sich auf jeden Fall gezeigt hat, ist, dass Ulm es durchaus auch geschafft hat, eine Entwicklung zu nehmen, jetzt auch in den ersten zwölf Spieltagen. Ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt war, dass man am Anfang diese Spiele nicht über die siebzigste Minute zu Ende bringen konnte. Man musste sich in Ulm tatsächlich mal auseinandersetzen, dass ein Spieler 90 Minuten lang geht. Da hat es am Anfang total gefehlt, weil sie haben gegen Kaiserslautern, gegen Düsseldorf, gegen KSC, gegen Nürnberg sehr dramatisch quasi alle Spiele in der Schlussphase oder in der siebzigsten Minute verloren. Und das haben sie, würde ich jetzt sagen, hinter sich gelassen. Also auch die letzten drei Spiele, die drei unentschieden, die auch zweimal zu Null gespielt werden. Natürlich, man hat auch kein Tor vorne geschossen, aber man hat auch ganz kassiert gegen Magdeburg und Schalke, waren dann schon auch ein Erfolg aus sich in Ulm. Und ich würde auch sagen, sie haben zu dieser Stärke oder auch das, was das Spiel von Thomas Loehrle ja zum Beispiel auch auszeichnet. Also sie spielen klassischerweise im 3-4-3. Das hat sich jetzt auch in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren nicht verändert. Und er legt da absoluten Wert auf diese defensive Geschlossenheit, die defensive Arbeit. Also das heißt, der Stürmer ist der Erste, der defensive arbeitet. Und klar, du tust wieder den Letzten. Und da muss man schon sagen, dass wir zu dieser Stärke uns jetzt wieder zurückgefunden haben.
Definitiv. Ich war erstaunt. Man hat 13 Gegentore kassiert, ist damit die zweitbeste defensive der Liga. Man hat die meisten gewonnenen Zweikämpfe in der 2. Liga. Auch wenn diese Statistik etwas schwammig ist, ist es in dem Fall ja immer ein Trend zumindest, oder ein Indiz. Und man hat auch zum Beispiel die zweitmeisten abgefangenen Bälle in der 2. Liga. Also in vielen wichtigen Defensivstatistiken ist man sehr weit vorne dabei und das spricht dann eben für das, was du eben gesagt hast, Nadine. Wer sind denn die wichtigsten Spieler für Wörle und Ulm? Also du hast ja auch davon gesprochen, dass es diese mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit gibt, dass viele diesen Weg jetzt schon lange mitgehen. Wer sind denn da so die zentralen Stützen?
Ja, sehr spannend, wenn man sich jetzt den Saisonverlauf anschaut. Ich will noch kurz eine Zahl vorwegschicken, weil das vorhin auch kurz Thema war. Also Ulm ist in die Saison gegangen mit 131 Zweitliga-Spielen. Das hat in anderen Mannschaften ein Spieler. Das ist ein wirklich krass niedriger Wert. Und ja, wer sind die Säulen? Eine definitive Säule war oder ist eigentlich der Torhüter Christian Othardt, der Lettches Saison auf 16-mal zu Null gespielt hat, als einer der Bestwerte der ersten drei Profi-Ligen, der allerdings Ende September sich der Schlüsselbein gebrochen hat. Das heißt, es war erst einmal so ein Verlust, wo schon auch die Frage war, wie kann man das kompensieren? Wo es jetzt eine Plastide, an der der 5V4 Elbocum ausgeliehen ist, hat das jetzt sehr, sehr gut kompensiert, obwohl natürlich wenig Spielpraxis reingeworfen ist als Nummer zwei. Eine absolute Säule, auch in der Defensive, ist Philipp Stromm, gibt den zentralen Innenverteidiger. Ist im letzten Winter nach Ulm gekommen, hat ein paar Zweitligaspiele von Braunschweig gemacht, ging dann kurz nach Schweden, von einem Ausflug, von dem er selber sagt, okay, das hat ihn jetzt in seiner fußballerischen Karriere nicht so weit nach vorne gebracht. Aber der hat sich jetzt absolut zum Abwehrboss gemausert, absoluter Stabilitätsfaktor. Ja, und dann wird es spannend, weil eigentlich würde in dieser Aufzählung jetzt noch der Kapitän dazu zählen, der Johannes Reichert. Er spielt ja schon immer in Ulm, ist Ulmer, es ist ein hatzensfreien. Also, über den Johannes Reichert kann man sagen, das ist noch so ein Typ, wie man ihn im Profifußball haben will, der sich jetzt in Meniskus gerissen hat. Also der viel zuletzt aus, wurde dann aber auch gut ersetzt durch Thomas Geyer, auch einer, der seit 2019 in Ulm spielt, noch nie 2. Liga gespielt hat. Hat sich jetzt blöderweise auch in Meniskus gerissen. Und im Moment stellt sich so ein bisschen die Frage nach der Defensive dann, also jetzt vor allem mit Blick aufs Spiel in Berlin, wem Thomas Müller da noch aufstellen kann oder was so die Alternativen sind. Ich würde schon auch noch, also den kann man auch nennen, man kann auch einen auf jeden Fall nennen, Romario Roesch, der spielt auf der linken Schiene. Gebirziger Neu Ulmer, also hier einer über die Donau, auch Ulmer Jugendspieler und so weiter, geht immer so ein bisschen, ja, fällt immer so ein bisschen unterm Radar, aber macht da, reißt er auf seiner linken Bahn Kilometer und Kilometer ab und ja, hat schon, ist jetzt schon viele Kämpferischen in Polen, sozusagen auch.
Und vielleicht ist ja auch Felix Hiegel zu nennen, der 4 von erst 10 Saisontoren selber erzielt hat, der Mittelstürmer von Ulm. Wenn ich tatsächlich spannend finde, auch bei Ulm ist Maurice Krattenmacher, du hast ihn schon, oder wir haben ihn kurz erwähnt, der vom FC Bayern aufgekaufte Unterharinger. Der ist ein echt, also neudeutsch würde man sagen, echter Baller. Also der kann schon richtig was am Ball und traut sich auch was. Also ich glaube, ist der so dieser X-Faktor im Ulmerspiel, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, also ich glaube, er ist es noch nicht, aber er könnte es werden. Vielleicht muss man da noch dazusagen, Ulm hat ja nach dem Aufstieg in die 2. Liga eigentlich den besten Spieler verloren, und das war Leonardo Cienza, der 50 Kilometer weiter nach Heidelberg gerextet ist, der erste Bundesliga, also einen Schritt von der 3. Liga in die 1. geschafft hat. Auch bevor er nach Ulm kam, im ersten FC Magdeburg, lief er aber nicht so ganz glücklich für ihn. Ich kenne da die Hintergründe nicht, aber das war auf jeden Fall nicht so eine Station, wie es funktioniert hat. Als es dann natürlich klar war, wurde auch ein nettes Saison-Spieler, dass er Ulm verletzt hat, hat sich schon auch die Frage gestellt, wie man den kompensieren kann. Es war klar, man kann ihn nicht 1 zu 1 ersetzen, aber man kann es versuchen. Ich glaube, in Mois Krattenmacher, aber auch Aaron Keller, der zuletzt nicht so viel gespielt hat, weil er verletzt war, sind so zwei Spieler, die das Potenzial mitbringen. Was klar ist, ist, dass sie noch Zeit brauchen, um sich möglicherweise dahingehend zu entwickeln.
Es sind jetzt noch fünf Spiele bis zur Winterpause. Man spielt gegen Hertha als nächstes, dann gegen Fürth, Hannover, den HSV und dann Münster. Ich sehe da zwei Spiele, die, glaube ich, den Ulmann Hoffnung bereiten und andere Spiele, die eher Sorgenfalten bereiten. Was ist denn jetzt das Ziel für die noch laufende Hinrunde?
Ja, ich glaube, es muss sein, dass man mindestens einen, besser noch zwei Siege, auf jeden Fall einfährt in diesem Festprogramm. Wobei, dazu will ich sagen, ich rote Maße, du zählst Münchner dazu. Zu den möglichen Kandidaten, wo man einen Sieg holen könnte. Das letzte Aufeinandertreffen in Münchner. Endete von SSV nicht so gut. Hat zwei zu drei verloren. Aber egal, vielleicht haben sie das ja auch so hinter sich gelassen. Definitiv muss da das Ziel sein, sich einen Sieg zu holen und sich auch für das, was man defensiv investiert und leistet, auch zu belohnen.
Ich nehme an, dass die Infrastruktur des Vereins unter den Jahren, in denen man teilweise sogar in der Oberliga gespielt hat, massiv gelitten hat. Wie steht es denn um die Arbeitsbedingungen des SSV? Und tut sich da durch diese zwei Aufstiege dahingehend etwas? Also investiert man jetzt in Steine? Oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen, gerade den Zustand in Ulm?
Ja, also ganz grundsätzlich kann man, glaube ich, sagen, dass Club und Stadt, also die Stadt Ulm, vom sportlichen Erfolg so ein bisschen überwohlt wurde. Also, dass der sportliche Erfolg dann doch zu schnell ging für das, was man hat quasi abseits vom Platz noch für Themen angehen müssen oder die man angehen muss. Ja, im Moment läuft zum Beispiel, also Ulm bekommt jetzt ein Fernprojekt, das ganz lange auch in der Schwebe war, das soll 2025 starten. Das ist natürlich so was Grundsätzliches, was andere Vereine schon ganz kurz lange haben. Dann ist es so, ja, auf der Geschäftsstelle ist natürlich gerade ganz viel Betrieb. Also letztes Jahr konnte man die Mitarbeiter, die der Geschäftsführer hatte, an zwei Händen abzählen. Funktioniert natürlich in der 2. Liga nicht mehr. Es sind natürlich jetzt auch andere finanzielle Mitte da, aber auch da muss man jetzt die Strukturen schaffen, dass das alles so seinen Weg gehen kann. Und das ganz, ganz große Thema, und das wird, glaube ich, auch ein Schlüsselthema sein für die Perspektive des Profifußballs in Ulm, ist die Frage nach dem Stadion. Und auch so ganz grundsätzlich, unabhängig davon, ob man jetzt in der 2. oder 3. Liga spielt, ist das eine Frage, die beantwortet werden muss, wenn man weiterhin Profifußball in Ulm haben will.
Kannst du die Thematik kurz ausführen?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob ja schon mal in Ulm Dona Stadion war.
Leider noch nicht, aber es ist ja schon ein Schmuckkästchen, ne?
Ja, also auch an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das Dona Stadion ist schon so ein kleiner Ort für, ich sage jetzt mal Fußballromantiker. Es ist sehr nostalgisch, sehr traditionell, aber auch sehr in die Jahre gekommen. Und das Thema ist einfach, es ist kein reines Fußballstadion. Es wird weiterhin noch als Leichtathletikstadion verwendet. Das heißt, es gibt auch eine Tatanbahn, die da ums Spielfeld rumliegt. Und es hat natürlich infrastrukturell ganz viele Probleme und ganz viele Anforderungen. Man ist jetzt auch, ja, man hat von der DFL auch die Lizenz quasi unter Auflagen bekommen. Man müsste das Stadion überdachen. Also, es hat 10.000 Stehplätze, wovon 10.000 nicht überdacht sind. Und natürlich noch ganz, ganz viele andere bauliche Maßnahmen. Und das ist jetzt im Prinzip so der Grundkonflikt, den auch die Stadt Ulm oder auch die Politik zu beschäftigen hat. Wie geht man damit um? Also, investiert man in dieses Stadion, in diesen Standort. Die andere Überlegung wäre, dass der SSV Neu baut. Dafür bräuchte es aber natürlich auch ein Grundstück, eine Infrastruktur, Drumkippen und so weiter. Und natürlich würde ja auch ein neu gebautes Stadion jetzt nicht bis nächstes Saison stehen. Das wäre dann ein Projekt für die nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre. Und ja, letztlich muss man sagen, wahrscheinlich der Profifußball, so wie es jetzt ist, mit Donaustadion und den Gegebenenheiten nicht zukunftsfähig, weil es auch die wirtschaftliche Profitabilität, sage ich jetzt mal, auserzählt ist. Also die Werbeflächen sind meiner Meinung nach ausvermarktet. Der Businessbereich ist mit 1000 Businessplätzen ausvermarktet. Man kann unüberdachte Stehplätze jetzt auch nicht, da kann man jetzt die Tickets auch nicht exorbitant weiter erhöhen. Da liegt man jetzt bei 17 Euro pro Ticket. Ja, da würde natürlich ein, ich sage jetzt mal, generales Stadion, das auch eine reine Fußballarena oder Fußballstadion wäre, schon ganz anders profitabel sein können.
Wenn wir jetzt beim Thema Zukunft gerade sind, dann lass uns natürlich auch gerne auf das Saisonende gucken und darüber hinaus, wie jeder will in der Liga bleiben. Gleichzeitig wird sich Ulm bewusst sein, dass das mit den Bedingungen einfach schwer wird. Also, wie erpicht ist man auf den Klassenerhalt und wie plant man mittelfristig seine Zukunft? Wo will man denn ungefähr sich einpendeln in den nächsten Jahren? Gibt es da Angaben zu?
Ja, also, so überstehend ist natürlich der Klassenerhalt. Das ist ja irgendwo auch klar. Wenn man jetzt in der Liga steht, dann werden wir das auch halten. Ich sag jetzt mal, ich bin da auch ganz guter Dinge. Reden wir in einem halben Jahr noch mal drüber. Ja. Aber auch das wurde vor, dass es so relativ klar kommuniziert. Da würde ich auch einen Geschäftsführer August Hiele zitieren. Ulm muss verstehen, dass der Profifußball auch weitergeht, wenn man aus der 2. Liga absteigen würde. Dann geht man in die 3. Liga und kann auch da profitabel wirtschaften, kann einen guten Job machen und so weiter. Ich glaube, da spricht einfach diese große Sorge oder diese große Angst in Ulm an, die einfach aus der Vergangenheit herrührt mit diesen drei Insolvenzen. Ja, dass man einfach Bedenken hat, dass das alles so auf einem soliden Fundament steht, wirtschaftlich und so weiter. Und im Prinzip ist das schon auch mit, neben dem Sportlichen, natürlich das große Ziel, dass man sagen muss, man will wirtschaftlich solide dastehen und niemand soll hier irgendwie Angst haben, dass es in einer 4. Insolvenz enden würde. Und da bin ich aber ja auch guter Dinge, auch mit Blick auf das, was in den vergangenen Jahren passiert ist und wie da gearbeitet wurde, dass da jetzt schon ein Team am Werk ist, dass das in die richtigen Fahnen hängt.
Als ich gerade noch über Themen außerhalb des Platzes bei Ulm nachgedacht habe, sind mir ehrlich gesagt natürlich nicht so viele eingefallen, aufgrund der wenigen Berührungspunkte in den letzten Jahren. Ein Thema, da hoffe ich gar nicht, dass ich dich damit überrolle, ist aber natürlich schon die Tendenzen in der Fanszene. Ich glaube, das hat in den letzten Jahren ein Stück weit Schlagzeile gemacht, dass der SSV Ulm Probleme haben soll mit Hooligans, mit übergriffigem Verhalten im Blog. Kannst du das eventuell ein wenig ausführen und auch sagen, wie der Verein damit umgeht? Ich will jetzt kein riesiges Fass aufmachen, aber ich glaube, dass man das immer ansprechen sollte, wenn man die Chance dazu hat.
Ich glaube, dass da in den vergangenen Jahren etwas überspitzt darüber berichtet wurde. Das kann ich jetzt auch aus meiner Perspektive als Journalistin sagen. Ich glaube, dass das Thema vielleicht auch von Medien und so weiter oder ausentstehenden Personen, die jetzt vielleicht in Ulm nicht vor Ort sind, größer gemacht wurde als es ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass Ulm eine größere– ich sage jetzt links oder rechtsextremes– Hooligan, was auch immer ein Problem hat, als andere Vereine. Ich glaube aber, dass es natürlich schwer ist– oder ich glaube nicht, sondern ich weiß, dass es schwer ist –,Dass ein bisschen den Ruf der Vergangenheit auszuräumen. Es gab Probleme, es gab Probleme im Fernsehen, es gab auch Übergriffe, es gab auch Aktionen bei Auswärtsspielen und so weiter. Da muss man aber schon fragen, die liegen acht, neun, zehn Jahre zurück, wenn nicht sogar noch weiter. Deswegen würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass es ohne Fanprobleme gibt. Was natürlich immer auch so einen Aufstieg und so ein größeres Interesse mit sich bringt, ist eben, dass noch mehr Leute sich im Stadion tun, vielleicht auch Leute, die man nicht unbedingt da haben möchte. Aber dass es anderen Vereinen ähnlich geht. Ohne zum Beispiel da vielleicht noch eine Aktion herauszuheben, das war, ich glaube, im letzten Frühjahr, da hat tatsächlich, das ist der D-Block, das ist der Heimblock. Es gibt auch so ein Fanfach, Dachverband D-Block, wo sich verschiedene Gruppierungen untereinander sammeln. Die haben einmal ein ganz klares Statement rausgegeben und da war ich selber von überrascht, weil ich das nicht mitbekommen hatte. Es gab wohl einen Übergriff im Block oder ja, anzügliche Bemerkungen und so weiter. Und da hat sich der Block ganz klar positioniert und gesagt, wir verurteilen das, das hat bei uns in der Kurve nichts zu tun und so weiter. Und das hat es halt in der Vergangenheit eigentlich so nicht gegeben. Das war für mich schon so ein Zeichen, dass auch die Fans jetzt realisieren, dass natürlich nicht nur die Aufmerksamkeit auf dem SSV Ulm größer ist, sondern auch die Aufmerksamkeit auf der Fanszene.
Damit haben wir das doch auch eingeordnet. Ich wollte da eben mal eine Einordnung von möglichst nahe dran, denn auch das habe ich halt nur mitbekommen. Wie es denn immer so ist, weiß man nicht, was davon dann überspitzt sein könnte, was davon hängen bleibt, wann das genau ist. Man kriegt nur Tendenzen mit. Deswegen vielen lieben Dank dafür die Einordnung. Das hilft natürlich auch total. Und dann können wir auch langsam zum Endliche leiten. Mona, Nadine, vielen Dank für eure Zeit. Wenn ich jetzt nichts vergessen habe, dann oder ihr gretet schon mal dazwischen, wenn irgendein Punkt nicht aufgekommen ist, den ihr unbedingt besprochen haben wollt. Wenn nicht, schweigt für immer. Gut, ich glaube, dann haben wir es. Dann bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, vielen lieben Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit in dieser Folge. Vielen lieben Dank für alle UnterstützerInnen dieses Podcasts. Da, wie gesagt, nochmal natürlich auch die Erwähnung, www.rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub ist eure Adresse. Das ermöglicht nicht nur, dass Max das hauptberuflich machen kann, sondern ermöglicht auch, dass zum Beispiel Eva oder auch ich hier freiberuflich mit dazusteuern können, dass so viele Formate am Leben erhalten bleiben können und dass sich immer weiter aufbaut und der Rasenfunk bald hier irgendwie die Sportlandschaft prägt. Also vielen lieben Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.